getting in and out and trying to be a
day trader
as a retail investor is a suckers game
today right because of these bots and
because of the quants and
high speed trading our frequency trading
this kind of stuff makes it impossible
for a retail investor to compete
writ large yeah
it's very tough uh knox is you know
considers himself a traitor i do not i'm
writing you know in-depth analysis that
i don't budge on for years i mean that's
kind of my
you know my niche is that if i'm writing
about the company i'm ready to go to bat
for it i'm ready to take on the market
like i know the market is going to come
for me and it's going to tell me i'm
wrong and my thesis is this you know
in price and price movement
so you know uh we've you know i've held
personally and then the i o fund has
also held companies that had 50 to 60
drawdowns i mean one of our you know
classic calls was roku at 30
and it looks like a darling today but
there were many times that roku is down
i think three times uh in the last three
years roku is down 60
roku seems like the most impossible bet
to make to me as a venture investor
because
you have apple tv as an incumbent you
have google as an incumbent and then you
have these other big streaming services
who you know maybe they don't have
hardware yet but maybe they could buy
something and so walk me through
how you have the audacity when something
like roku is trading at 30 bucks a share
you know whatever a couple years ago
to say that company can compete against
the duopoly google and apple and then
amazon
all three of them well actually two out
of the three do not care about margin on
hardware the only one who cares about
margin on hardware is apple
so you're up against three giants who
don't care about money
and roku does the same thing how do they
win
i think that's a great question and it
the audacity is a great word for it
because um the wall street will always
make you think that you're wrong so you
got to be really firm on why you might
be right and so all this has been
carefully written about but a i would
call roku technically the incumbent here
because
they were the first to market
and you know they actually
came out around the same time as
rehasting netflix so um it just took
this long for ad supported
um to come out avod uh versus
subscription video on demand uh to be
picked up specifically not by the court
cutters you and i but by the brand
advertisers and so the other thing is
that they own the whole stack which
uh google owned the whole stack and
amazon eventually got into but they had
designed an operating system that was
flawless for very cheap and it fits well
into low cost television sets or smart
tvs
all that is great because they have this
hardware and they have the operating
system that they can do very well with
but ultimately
roku's path to a lot of wall street
gains
still is today is that they are an ad
platform
so we are moving into a world where
brand advertisers which are on you know
you know linear pay tv are moving on to
um
uh they're cutting you know they're
moving towards the cord cutters so
they're going over to ott so budweiser
for the first time did not advertise in
the super bowl um they are moving over
to roku i mean you know roku and its
competitors those brand dollars are
actually worth as much as mobile
pay tv ad dollars have been a holy grail
for some time so you're talking your
pizza huts pizza hut can't really
advertise on facebook as effectively as
they can advertise on a television
screen
and if you can add in the data that
comes from you viewing ott set top box
or smart tv roku's
you know android google
that data is now informing your pizza
hut ads your budweiser ads
whatever it might be
that's a big deal for paid tv
advertisers who did not budge and did
not spend on mobile very much
um so it's a budget migration yeah it
takes a really deep analysis of that
because
what you're also realizing in all of
this is okay sure hardware is a
commodity but audience is not right and
the ability to aggregate an audience
together like that even though you can
commodify the hardware
there was another trend going on which
is i don't know if you've had this
experience but with my nba league pass
there's an option to turn off ads hulu i
can turn off ads hbo max no ads
netflix no ads disney plus no ads so i'm
looking at consumers and thinking wait a
second the highest end consumers
are opting out of advertising
um you know across some of these top
platforms like when's the last time you
saw an ad right and i oh i actually paid
for youtube i don't know if you do this
do you pay for the youtube premium
service that takes ads out i'm curious
if either of you pay for them oh my god
it's the greatest
bargain in the history of
media you don't know how many youtube
ads you're watching but my lord just not
having to click skip the ad after five
seconds 20 times a week or a day or how
long you're on there it's incredible so
where do those advertising dollars go
roku right like it's a really
interesting uh funneling there of
consumers
yeah and i guess uh the other way to
reframe it is that technically roku has
always had the biggest audience by a
small lead but how were they able to do
that for so long with google and amazon
chasing them and apple is tv is i'm not
even sure if they're still are they
producing much for that anymore i don't
even know it didn't do well it's known
to have not done well
i always thought this is a very weird
thing about apple you know like for them
to do content always seemed like
strange to me because they're not
willing to do the content that a lot of
people would want which is adult fare fx
hbo sopranos game of thrones just
wouldn't work on their platform because
they're unwilling to
show sex or violence to that level right
they want ted lasso stuff
so i yeah i don't
understand apple's
mission there i guess they have to do
something with that money
let's talk about that you have these
giant war chests what is the story with
these how do you value companies and
their usage of
capital in relation to m a and putting
it to work because i mean beats was a
completely uninspiring acquisition
is tim cook a great ceo for not
acquiring companies and staying focused
and making sure everything's built there
or is this a huge mistake how do you
think about that with apple specifically
i'm curious
the price keeps marching higher so
regardless i guess of what i think apple
has done very well with tim cook um but
if you were to you know ask me casually
what do i think of tim cook and i'm not
a big fan i have no it and it's really
important to always stick to your thesis
as a investor which means like i don't i
need you know someone just put on
twitter the other day you know peter
lynch like you've got to be able to sit
back and watch other people make money
on what you passed on and i'm okay with
uh passing on apple even with the gains
because i couldn't find the growth
market for the company i mean i get it
iphones you know
you know high dollar
average sales price etc but at great
margins
cash machine i mean this company's a
cash machine
i just can't find the growth market and
that's my investing style so i
even with all of that cash i don't know
the growth markets that apple is going
into in the near term
and that's why i stayed away
recently
in today's startup landscape committing
to security and compliance is vital for
growth and proof of your company's
security posture has never been more
important as you scale you might start
to receive more sock two requests from
customers and that's where drata comes
in drata is an advanced automation
platform used by some of the world's
leading chief information
security officers or csos strata will
help you successfully meet requirements
support enterprise deal flow and
continually track compliance strata also
helps customers easily prepare for and
clear sock 2 and other audits so you can
go from zero to audit ready in a matter
of weeks need more take it from philip
martin chief security officer at
coinbase and here's his quote it became
clear to me right away that drata is an
engineering powerhouse the solution
they've developed is well ahead of other
market players their approach to deep
native integrations provides users with
the most advanced automation available
so check out drata's five-star reviews
on g2 and see why companies like clear
close smart recruiter and the good face
project work withdrawda for their
compliance needs twist listeners can get
15 off and waived implementation fees at
drata.com twist d-r-a-t-a dot com slash
twist